[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about what whatever we want and
today we have kalimi
[Applause]
previous to this episode that you guys
could catch on patreon kelly was saying
that she's
wants to write a book
about your life
about the things you went through and i
think just like
one one thing that popped up in my head
was like all right you've been behind
the scenes in business and you've been
around celebrities and all this stuff
and crazy money and like that rock style
rock star lifestyle right but it's just
recently where you're in front of the
camera not behind
has that changed like just having an
audience just having that kind of people
knowing i'm so much more stuck up now
i know my worth i'm scared just kidding
well like that attempt like you've been
behind the scenes and then now you're
transitioning
is that different for you like being of
the face instead of being like you've
been in entertainment supporting and
doing all that stuff behind yeah it's
definitely a challenge switching from
behind a camera to the front because now
that you know you have to be a lot more
vulnerable and for me i've always been
i'm so used to behind the scenes i'm
used to being very like low-key yeah but
now you have to just be more open and
with your life and it's definitely a
challenging challenge you have to be
camera ready
oh my god makeup every day like i just
sit in a makeup chair getting my hair
done two hours every day it's two hours
makeup and hair yeah [ __ ] are they
turning into mrs doubtfire
that'd be a good spin-off the crazy ones
are like for like x-men or whatever
they're sitting in the chair because
they gotta put like [ __ ] reptile skin
on mystique yeah they're at 2 a.m yeah
and then they're not done until like 3
p.m and then now they're ready to go
film yeah which is pretty that's
exhausting that's exhausting have you
dealt with like
crazy fans or like haters or like we
like when you're always behind the
scenes it's always like you're insulated
right you're creating
content you're having fun but then you
never have to deal with
being in the public eye but then now
that's changed for you have you like
dealt with that directly and like
and has it like [ __ ] with your mind and
all that stuff because like a lot of
youtubers they quit because they can't
deal with the direct just don't read it
like because for me like when the show
first aired i think there's a lot of
criticism and a lot of things on twitter
yeah especially reality tv people watch
it to talk [ __ ] all day long everybody
has a judgment everybody has a has their
own opinion but in the day like just
can't let it get to you just you know
know what it is but i wish there was a
disclaimer in front of reality tv shows
that go
look here dumbass this is still a show
so some things
aren't are out of context you don't know
what really is going on so don't judge
anybody in here you [ __ ] dumb ass but
that's what makes it fun are you killing
feel them when people like because
kelly's all nice and not people are
going in on it because i don't even
understand what really happened they i
don't know i think people watch because
they have miserable lives like i'm
laughing to the bank so i don't give
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's the best attitude to
have that's the way to do it
that's the best way damn that's a
boss-ass answer i've never been able to
say that
anthony has only cried in banks
anthony's picture of paparazzi pictures
just
not in banks out of base he gets kicked
out of banks
he's crying
your money is not good here son
but you know with all reality shows that
when you sign a contract they give you a
disclaimer it says this is gonna this
will mess up your emotional
you might have like a mental stress
anxiety whatever whatever they have a
disclaimer so if you commit suicide
don't sue us right that's pretty much
yourself
i bet that you being behind the scenes
and being exposed to this prepared you
versus someone that's just like never
been in entertainment and all of a
sudden they're in front of the camera
and then they have to deal with all the
crazy stuff because a lot of reality tv
uh people
they go through some [ __ ] like there's
like suicides and there's just like all
kinds of depression that happens
afterwards but when you're in
entertainment you're probably just like
yeah it definitely helps a little bit
but of course i've seen comments that
makes me really mad yeah i just blocked
their ass i'm like
easy you're also an ep right so you get
to have control over the edit i don't or
you don't not for reality reality is
hard because with scripted you know
there's a beginning middle and reality
you just you don't know because the
story takes different ways and you have
to stay present and have to stay
vulnerable and there's just no way to do
both so they're just filming everything
and they carve the story out later or
they kind
right and then when they film of course
a lot of things gets cut out but um
you know are you a villain do i look
like a villain i don't think you're a
villain but but on the show you know how
that is you don't feel like a villain
but you look like you can play a villain
yeah you can do it there's not a villain
in season one what about season two i'm
not sure yet depends on editing do the
villains on your could you have villains
on the show i would imagine i think all
of our characters are pretty
well-rounded i think because we're not
playing we're not filming something like
the housewives we're filming stuff
that's like a little bit more you know
we're all and also things in real life
we're all friends right you know so
there's no villains
yeah i think we'll take a hit here and
there there's gotta be
episodic villains though to make it
juicy dude the housewives you know they
get hate yeah i feel think joe should
come on and be the villain i would i'll
take it he'd be a bad villain though
i don't think you're a good villain
you're just very laughable you're
likable dude i don't know i could be
pretty dislikable
[Laughter]
i haven't liked him saying that
this guy's cool man this guy's a nice
guy what a sweet guy too happy go lucky
i think i want to be like the broke guy
that thinks he's rich and like he comes
in and then like he uh
you know like those guys that are um
they're always faking it around people
that have
wealth or something and then they're
trying to find a way to like prove
themselves that they could stick so you
could be like a gold digger yeah sick
yeah that'd be pretty cool that'd be
pretty cool i don't think you're gonna
be a good good gold digger though i know
but i i'll try
there's no trying either do what you're
doing that's true you're right
i never even had i never even been
around gold diggers so i don't know how
what to mimic do you want to meet some
of my friends yeah
have you seen male 1 you use the word
friends very loosely not what there's
male gold diggers right in the rich
world there's there's lady and then
there's male like gigolos right
have you ran into any yeah what's your
gold digger stories because i feel like
you attract a lot of gigolos some dudes
that want to hang on they want to pay
for everything they're like kelly take
care of me kelly please i don't think i
have you ever seen the day you got five
right here you ever see the dave
chappelle uh oprah's sketch where he uh
got oprah pregnant
it's basically that and you just stayed
at home
yep you used a baller [ __ ] that's a life
right because we're not anywhere near
your level but then
i've seen bars house on youtube just
bart though maybe bart he has to live 6
000 miles away from here though
that's true
but i think for guys it's like you're
either
it's either uh other guys trying to
pitch you business ideas all the time to
invest in their ideas
and then if you're a single guy
then it's like
the girls that
come after you
and that's it i don't know anything else
you can tell joe's thought about this
one a lot
you just got out of a relationship right
yes you said it's a very toxic
relationship what did you learn about
yourself i learned to create healthier
boundaries
i learned it's okay to say no
and then i learned that um
sometimes you gotta put your own needs
first so you're very servicing you can
pour from empty glass well because in
the asian culture especially as a woman
you always give give give and you always
put other people's needs before your own
you're a gigolo's dream come true
apparently
so now i gotta you know it's more like
self-love self-discovery and realizing
you can't pull from empty glass and
secular boundaries and communicate what
about mental health have you learned
about yourself i have a negative core
belief that i'm not good enough a lot of
i think a lot of asian
you know people are like i think that's
true you know yeah because it's just how
you're brought up
right and then you either turn around
and say [ __ ] you parents you were wrong
this whole time
not only am i good enough i'm better
than your loser ass or you turn around
and you stay even more like not good
enough
and it's like a weird never healthy
balance yeah but also your parents might
not know better because that's how
they're brought up right yeah and
empathy yeah yeah
you might not know better um but also uh
i forgot i was gonna say forget it sorry
mental health mental health not good
enough and then um oh also another thing
is that in the asian culture we're never
taught to express our emotions how to
voice it right i don't know about you
guys but for me i was never taught how
to motion how to voice my emotions get
underneath say sorry yeah that's that's
the healthy way of doing it but talking
it out
but talking it out like i feel this way
right be able to communicate it properly
so for me my dad doesn't call me a [ __ ]
if i start talking about my feelings
that's what i'm saying you kind of coop
everything up until you blow up so you
don't know how to properly express your
emotions and talk things out i feel like
only
great depression white coal miners
understand our for what we went through
oh you come downstairs you're like dad
school's really hard and he goes we were
so poor i ate my cat i'm like all right
i'm gonna go back upstairs
time to study
but that's what i'm saying because asian
culture you're very kind of closed off
to emotions you know talk about it
that's because you know the white the
white kids growing up we had the wwe
like you learn about emotions
do you feel what the rock is cooking
it's a feeling
guys talk about their feelings into a
microphone yeah loudly
to everyone yeah like and they get in
each other's faces and tell each other
how they feel yeah and they use the
furniture to express themselves
no clothes so it's really just a
vulnerable state of being you know what
i mean like let me tell you something
brother
when you have two strong men in their
underwear talking about their feelings
brother
if more asian households would accept
wwe that's true i needed a more male
role model he's learned a lot
he learned so much not enough asian
wrestlers in the wwe yeah bro we didn't
have anybody
but but he was actually polynesian oh
yeah he was polynesian and he only made
me aspire to be diabetic that's it
today's video is brought to you by
kerology all right check this out guys
i
have never really washed my face until i
started working with curology and it's
been about maybe two almost three years
now that i've been using their products
and i'm a 37 year old man
and i don't know if this is anything to
brag about you look like you don't look
37
i don't know maybe
maybe i could be better or maybe i would
look older or maybe my skin would look
more destroyed
if i wasn't using this stuff but i can't
make any crazy claims all i can say is
that i do feel healthier and i do feel
like i'm more conscious of skin health
when i never was before back in the day
what i would do is i kind of still do
this till this day if i don't have their
products on me and i'm traveling but i
wash my hair and then i just move the
shampoo to my face and i watch that and
i call it a day and that would be my
only form of face wash but with curology
what they did is they pretty much helped
me out
and in a really effortless way it was
super simple
you know i just went on their website
and i basically told them my skincare
goals you know click a few things and
they customize it to you yeah i was like
i don't i don't want to be an old fart
you know i want to i want to be i want
to have nice
uh healthy young skin right and then a
licensed provider creates the whole
formula for you so it's made for your
skin and what your goals are yep and it
was super simple
and every month they send me a nice
little package that has a face wash it
has my custom formula and a moisturizer
so this is something that's important to
you and you want to up your skincare
level and look nice like joe he's 37 but
looks like he's in his mid-20s go to
curology.com off the record and you get
your first 30 days for free you have to
pay for shipping and handling which is
five bucks that's curology.com off the
record to get your first 30-day trial
for free you just got to pay for
shipping and handling go check it out
check it out check it out was doing the
clown asian i don't remember
doing the clown was he an asian
i don't remember i never got to see him
never got a good look at him i think he
had clown makeup never got a good look
at the fella is there any asian female
wwe yeah well not well we actually have
a friend well her name's china but she's
not asian oh yeah true
we didn't have representation though
wait is this someone that trained with
you wasn't [ __ ] yeah
friend she's a professional she's a
professional wrestler like that kind of
wrestling
yeah and she's taiwanese oh okay
that's awesome
it's really cool it's pretty funny does
she express her feelings no she just
goes i'm not good enough and then she
puts me
she needs a mic
mommy daddy i'm not good enough and then
she gets on her knees and says sorry yes
she says i'll never be china
yeah
i'm gonna do my homework
[Laughter]
mom comes out she's like well did you
win it like this what if okay i had to
talk with our mutual friend joey right
so like he was saying that
now he realizes that all the trauma and
things that he's been through
drove him to where he is today so that
energy
that that was painful was turned into
something positive and i was like oh
you're you know what you're right like i
think
what if the whole you're i'm not good
enough
was something that pushed us to work
hard to get there 100 and then so like
yeah it was it was it was like it was
like dark energy that got us there and
it kind of sucked but then it got us
there everything happens for a reason
right yeah i was talking to
uh one of my business mentors about that
and he was saying that it's it's cool
like there's you know like people that
have a dark past and they get driven by
it it's still unhealthy even though
you're successful because you're
successful and you're empty but if you
know how to control that feeling that's
when your mental health is good so like
joey if he's just like
smashed and he only did and he buried
himself in work but that's almost his
way of escaping that's like being in a
trap still even if you look ex like
wealthier yeah he has material success
because it's driven by the dark energy
but it's not fulfillment
so it's like you still need to be in
control and once you're able to be in
control and be able to tap in and
control your emotions rather than your
emotions just leading you that's when
it's like like zen and good yeah yeah
work-life balance i hear what you're
saying but
you look like i also have let's hear
this thing it was like the wwe that's
what bothers me about this guy okay okay
so
bart is talking about how how hard his
parents were on him and all this [ __ ]
yeah okay but then i i take one look at
him and i'm like how hard were they on
him because right now his [ __ ] laptop
bro
bro
i think they could have done a little
bit of a better job being a little
harder on this guy there's a [ __ ]
ring on his stupid [ __ ] little laptop
because he puts his iced coffee on it
and if his old man would just
harder on him he wouldn't do this [ __ ]
because he would know the value of a
[ __ ] dollar that's how rich he is i'm
trying to match her shame on my coaster
i asked for a napkin you know how
expensive these are bro this is my
playing empire i literally [ __ ] saw
that like two videos ago and i was like
my parents would [ __ ] kill me bling
empire culture nick would you rather
have trouble oh yes
not really
my parents were harder on me than that's
what i just found out it was ineffective
my parents were hard enough bro you know
what i'm saying
but i mostly got that from the wwe
though
i did i did
let me tell you something about
electronics brother
[Laughter]
damn they really brought up the american
youth and also can i say one more thing
it's still on there you pointed it out
but it's still on [ __ ] dude and he's
got a water ring on his laptop live your
life bro i mean just not put it back bro
this guy this this badass lets his kid
draw in [ __ ] marker on his laptop and
he's like i left it there because it's
kind of cute and i'm like
yeah this is pretty cute though that was
really cute
that is different like you you you
you're raising taika so [ __ ]
differently from how you were raised
because i i'm like man there's so many
times where i would have thrown him like
a [ __ ] football and just kicked his
hat boom and then saw him go all the way
up into the field but the field
[Laughter]
he just dude tyka could draw on bart
with a marker and bart will get it
tattooed
that's how embarrassing he is probably
so different it's gonna be interesting
how he turns out yeah because it's i
think what's cool is uh knowing terms
like adhd and whatever and like being
able to identify things that helps out
because
the things that my dad beat my ass for i
realized
he had the same [ __ ]
but i think he was beating my ass
because it's almost like a self-loathing
you know like i know i can't pay
attention how come my son can't pay
attention either i want to beat it out
of them so it's projection like he hated
himself in you so he beat you because
he's beating himself yeah but now that i
understand i have a hard time paying
attention so when i see like taika i try
to like unplug the moon bounce at
someone's birthday i'm like
i know where it's coming from i also
want to kick your ass but
i know where it's coming from i'm able
to pull him aside no you can't do that
so you have more patience with him and
you kind of talk to him you understand
yeah yeah he also has like half of my
jeans so
it's part of the brains yeah yeah
what kind of monster wants to unplug a
moon back he's dude this guy at his
cousin's birthday
so he keeps throwing [ __ ] into the moon
bounce right
and then uh because i think he likes
seeing things bouncing off the floor of
the moon bounce when people when kids
are jumping so i tell them like hey stop
doing that there's a bunch of kids in
there you can hurt someone you can put
rocks in there or whatever and then i'm
gonna break something i'm like if you do
this one more time i'm gonna put you in
timeout
like 30 minutes later i see him throwing
flower petals into the moon bounce again
that's better
sweet i got the type of ambiance
i go up to taika but i'm pissed at this
point cause i already lectured him like
20 times i'm like taika why are you
throwing [ __ ] into the moon bounce and
he's like
because it's so beautiful i'm like oh
[ __ ] what do i say
oh
now he just sees all these flower petals
floating in there and i'm like okay i
see what you're seeing now because i was
doing it as a nuisance but he's seen it
as like yo doesn't everyone love flowers
oh except cycles like stewie you walk
away and he's like dumbass
[ __ ] little flowers
[Laughter]
you won't let me do rocks i'll do flower
powder when does he try to unplug the
moon bounce though every time right when
they set it up and it's full of kids he
likes him
has he succeeded
where he unplugged it in the first two
birthdays he has but now i know to look
out for that so the minute they set up
the moon balance he's a serial unplugger
and i'm like already waiting for him i'm
like no you can't be back here
because he wants to see it deflate on
everybody that makes sense that's
hilarious he's like why do you keep
doing that i want to see the world
crumble
that is the beginning of a [ __ ]
villain story dude yeah that's [ __ ]
razz al gold modern day omen story i
know it's like a football game and
there's an explosion and tyka's going
in the making he's a [ __ ] troll man
dang he
he develops a weather machine that
creates tsunamis and [ __ ] and it goes
into different cities and he's like
and then you lecture them isn't rain
beautiful
and you're like oh i gotta let them do
it as a typhoon take some [ __ ] city
building parts like
the moon balance just to see it crumble
on kids that's pretty funny
that's pretty fun i'm going to be
googling that later yeah yeah but then
now i know my mom and my dad kick my ass
because they're probably like like when
i was a kid they're probably like why
can't you just play like regular kids
because that's my thought i see a moon
bounce being erected all the kids take
off their shoes go inside they start
jumping up and down for like normal
people and then you don't have to worry
about them for an hour this [ __ ]
is already going to the side doing all
kinds of other [ __ ] i'm like okay just
play like regular kids
but that's unique though my parents were
like moon bounce we had to eat our cat
[Music]
you